-Finally it's time for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, we do this thing every week where I send out
a hashtag and we ask you guys to respond to that topic.
So, since we're headed into prom season,
I sent out the hashtag "#PromFail,"
and I asked you guys to share some funny or weird things
that happened at your prom.
Within minutes, it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now I thought I'd share some of my favorite
#PromFail tweets from you guys.
This first one is from @jend7512. She says...
-Sounds cool. -That is cool.
-Next one's from @AlliAlliAlli33.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-"Boop!"
-This next one is from @Boho-Beau. She says...
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Use a condiment, everybody. Use a condiment.
-Yeah. No.
[ Laughter ]
-Next one is from @claydoughrocks. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good joke. Why?
-Oh, why? Why?
Why would they do that?
-This next one is from @SaiyanaBrief. She says...
-Oh. -Hm.
Wow. That one just -- -Kind of like bragging.
-People did not enjoy that --
-I don't think they -- I don't think they liked that.
-I think the audience loved that one.
-You think so? Do you really?
Oh, because you think they were wrapped with attention?
They didn't make any noise. So they're like --
-Yeah, they took it. They go like...
-They took it in. -Yeah.
-Then they went, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
"She still has her $200 dress."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That's really a PromWin.
-Yeah, not a PromFail.
-With all these other losers with their puffy dresses.
"I can relate to it. I can relate to it
because I had to buy that expensive dress,
and I kept that dress, but you can never wear it again."
-Right. But she still has her $200 dress.
-She was just saying.
-And flaunting it in the faces...
-She's just saying, like, as a joke.
-You think it was a joke. -She doesn't really --
-But don't jokes elicit laughter from people?
[ Laughter ]
Like, when I was -- I was listening --
-Not necessarily. Not necessarily.
You heard me when -- -I heard you say it,
and then I heard the audience,
my friends in the audience, not respond at all,
'cause they were going like... "Hmm."
I wish -- Can we replay that? Can we replay that?
-No, no, I don't want to replay it.
-Let's just see it. Let's just see it real quick.
-SayanaBrief. She says...
-Ohh. -Hmm.
Wow. That one just -- -Kind of like bragging.
[ Laughter ]
I heard a couple ohh's. "Ohh."
-It wasn't complete silence.
-No, it was not complete silence.
It was like, "Ohh."
-Anyone here from Delaware?
-Yeah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go. I heard that. Welcome.
This last one here is from @lmhksu. She says...
Look at this. Look at -- Zoom in. Hey!
Those are our "Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of my favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.